[Music]
[Applause]
he's hall of famer two-time nba champ
10-time all-star and coach of the boys
basketball team at gulliver prep in pine
crest florida the former big east player
of the year ray allen back on the
program ray i was looking at your bio
you were in
england
you were in germany growing up
air force bases
uh do you speak german
no okay i did a little bit when i was
younger okay and then did you have an
english accent when you lived in england
when i was younger i certainly could put
one on well let's let me hear a little
bit of your english accent uh let me see
how are you
well that sounded like ray allen
well
i mean you you can you depend on what
part of uh the country and it sounds a
little different but you know it needs a
little work if i if i went back to
london
i think i can assimilate
did people make fun of you when you came
to the united states with an english
accent
i didn't come with an english accent but
i was extremely proper
so
[Laughter]
when i came from england i moved to
california so it kind of
it fit in there but then now going from
california to south carolina was when i
was in trouble
because i was way too proper for the
kids that i was in school
uh congrats on the 75th team but i'm
curious what happened behind the scene
with the 75th anniversary you know
everybody's putting on their jackets and
what what was the mood like
behind the scenes when everybody was
there for the 75th anniversary team
you know it was like a high school
reunion
just being
i'm walking in the room and uh like when
we first
you know you're going into the room and
on one side of the room uh all the guys
the all-stars were taking pictures
before the game
and all of us were sitting in there with
our jackets on our 75th jackets and uh
i'm speaking with uh james worthy with
bill walton
um
and robert parish and i'm just sitting
here thinking of myself i'm like
i i just you know no matter what you
achieve accomplish in your career you're
sitting here like i just remember when i
was 10 watching james worthy
play basketball not you know we come
down the floor we call ourselves the l.a
lakers anytime we went on the fast break
and just having this moment you just you
go back to when you're a kid and i think
for most of us
that's kind of where it takes you
because you remember these hit you know
what like a great song takes you back to
your childhood or to a favorite moment
of your life that's what seeing these
guys were like for me like seeing them
up close and personal just reminded me
of who i was growing up
did you walk up to jordan
well i i see jordan all the time like i
said
yeah i seen him last i played with him
the week before playing golf so i see
him
all the time but mj he actually
you know he was at daytona
you know for his uh for the race so
we were actually about to walk onto the
court
and you know magically
he appears into the hallway
and then the first thing he says he sees
magic as he comes through and you guys
seen it uh online and he he asked him
that he had his tennis shoes with him
and um we we were talking about you know
playing golf a little bit and then magic
kind of appeared you know at the same
time at the same time and
that's when that little uh that little
conversation happened and we just you
know it was just quintessential
magic jordan like we knew growing up and
to be able to be sitting here with these
guys and calling them peers now it's
like
it's so surreal but mike can't turn it
off like it's always on and he's there
saying the magic hey you got your shoes
let's let's go play one on one
but here's the thing i i tell people all
the time like when you when you're
playing a sport you're so good at it
you're a competitor
you don't go home and stop being a
competitor you know you can't change
your brain out like you end up being
that same person all the time now
you have to understand who you can
compete with and how you compete with
them and you know obviously you don't
want to compete with your wife at home
and when i when i play basketball
against my kids i compete with them but
i show them you know how the game works
and you're teaching them but
you still find ways to always challenge
those people around you and i think
that's who m is and that's who he's
always been and everybody for that
matter that has made it to
that level where you've been uh named
the 75 greatest of all times
there's a reason for that you know and a
lot of times those reasons set you on
that lonely path where you're sitting
there saying to yourself
man like i'm doing this by myself
because the things that you've wanted in
your life
not everybody has won how come you got
to shoot more how come you're still on
the floor how come you won't hang out
with us
those times when you take that separate
path are are why
the greats ended up being the greats
you also had to sacrifice your ego at
some point in your career because when
you first came into the league i mean
you were getting 25 a game and you were
dunking on people and then
so you get to the celtics and then you
is is that where it's is it discussed
that okay now i have to play a role or
what is my role with paul pierce and and
garnett and rondo
well between uh between
paul
myself and kevin we had an understanding
we did an interview
in the beginning of the year
and we were asked
if
it came to one last second shot
between the three of you who would take
it
and
the reporter asked us but i want you to
all answer at the same time
and so
paul answered me
kevin answered me and i answered the
open person
so
i think we walked into that season in in
the right frame of mind now
what it had just come from in seattle
playing the seattle like it was shoot
first play fast open
uh
launching threes left and right similar
to how golden state's playing today
so i remember in practice i come down
launch a three kg's on the block post
enough doc goes
ham on me you got to throw the ball down
low to kg he's wide open you got to get
him the ball
that's a good imitation of darkness yeah
i'm like doc i was open i want you to
throw the ball inside out man he's going
to find you he's unselfish
um and so you know we it was that it was
that position that point where we were
you you had to kind of rip apart and
have those uncomfortable conversations
early
where i wasn't going to be taking those
shots quick just like that in transition
i think over the course of our five
years together it evolved into that
because
doc started to understand you know what
my capabilities were and who i was and
he saw it firsthand you know what i was
capable of doing and even kevin is self
unselfish as he as he was you know on
the block uh setting screens
we started to understand that but when
you come together early
you do have to make those sacrifices you
do have to say
okay i'm gonna be 80
of who i've been
in order for this team to win
he's ray allen hall of famer two-time
nba champ that's the last time i'll ask
uh how did the beef start with kg and
pierce and rondo and why did it end how
did it end
uh i i don't
i didn't have any beef there wasn't
anything um they have with you
yeah they were upset that i uh went to
miami and
you know for me i
i was happy that i focused on the five
years that we spent together and then we
won in 2008 and that for me didn't
change anything so
uh this coming this past weekend i was
uh ecstatic to be there uh for kevin
because of
you know he and i grew up together
um i remember him 14 15 years old and
you know just the exuberance he had for
game of basketball and
you know we had a a kinsmanship as young
people and then obviously watching him
make it to the league so i was ecstatic
for him to get his jersey retired uh
well deserved and i
you know i wouldn't have wanted to be
any other place so i never had any uh
any ill will uh towards any of them uh
it was just unfortunate because when you
when you move on like we all do at some
point in our careers uh
you know you you
i i think it was more out of
uh
hurting and disappointment more than
anything but you know it's all good and
we're brothers and the one thing that we
have to
uh just hold on to is what we did
together and that is more important than
anything but when kg is on the
microphone
and then next thing you know he's
calling you out
yeah did you think
you know were you going to walk out
there 2kg
listen i i
you you have to go back because when
when paul got his juries retired
i actually didn't know about it and i
was in uh i was in l.a i had a uh
commercial to shoot
and
i happened and this is a funny story
because i was playing golf and
it was about 12
30 in the afternoon and i was playing
with uh with george lopez and anthony
anderson
in la
and george he
gets a hole in one
and so i was like we jumped up and down
and i was excited and i was like man
that was awesome and then i posted it
now 12 30 on the west coast at 3 30
on the east coast
paul was getting his jersey retired he
was in the garden and he's walking out
there and you know uh
kevin and rondo and docker and all them
were there and so i post a picture that
i was there and then everybody was
making a big deal about it because i
wasn't there and i was like i had no
idea and at that point
that was when i wasn't included you know
i wasn't invited and i you know so when
this came up i was like remember i don't
care what anybody says
i will always be a celtic and what
happened in 2008 is always going to be
one of my favorite moments in my life
and so
if you just had to get through this
period this this this
tough time and just men fences and i
think so
when kevin's jersey was being retired
i don't know if they knew i was going to
be there but i had on my schedule that i
was going to be there when i showed up i
think he was uh surprised i know
kendrick perkins was surprised that i
was there it was great to walk back in
the building and
i don't know how i was going to be
received i was assuming that some people
would boo me because they still you know
uh upset
um but when i walked in it was amazing
because everybody kind of cheered and
and and celebrated and then
uh when he called me up when he called
me out and he said it was good to see me
in the building i just had to walk up
there and give him a hug because i know
there's nothing scripted you know and i
didn't want to be
unemotional in that moment or or
you know in a position where i was just
like you know you want what do i do i
was like let me go get this man hug
because
not only is it good for he and i but
it's good for the people to see you know
so they understand like there's no we're
brothers there's no will between us
it was great to see
but but i didn't expect to see it
because i thought you know what i give
you credit because you've never spoke
ill of those guys
that you still have respect for them but
i realized kg was going to hold a grudge
and man can he hold a grudge ray like
you know at the hall of fame he's not
even talking to you there and you're in
the room with him
yeah and well here's the thing
when you look at
we look at you know i think about all
the teams
that won championships over the course
of history in any sport
one of the great things about tradition
young people young teams college teams
college players
they look up and aspire to be like those
championship teams and you you walk in
the building you see jerseys uh uh
retired and you see championships
celebrated
and and and i give a lot of credit
to detroit you know because you know i
follow rick hamilton he's you know a
brother of mine
and
he always is celebrating what they did
in 2004 with the pistons you know going
back and you know
somebody's getting a jersey retired he's
there they're just at the game's court
side and and i think for organizations
that's huge
you know just to have your your your
former players show up to games like i
honestly believe
you know and tell me i'm strange but i
think all former players should have
season tickets
at the places that they used to play you
know
just because you should have a footing
in and i'm not talking about the guy
paying for it i'm throwing it out there
like you know these teams should make
sure
that their guys are there so the the the
past play or the current players see it
and the fans understand the connection
to
to their past because you when you talk
about the nba now you got so many teams
with generations of fans
and just like i told you earlier like
you connect to the organization based on
how you grew up watching them so to
watch
if you're a milwaukee buck fan
and you see oscar robertson walk back in
the building or kareem
you know or
bobby dandridge you're like man
you know man these guys were my heroes
and i think every organization should
have that connection to their past
you wanted to be a laker
i did
i did that was my first nba game
you know i seen so i was i was uh
10 12 years old in my high school my
coach at the time he said
i walk out the court it's the fabulous
form at a time
and
they're playing the pistons i think this
was 1988.
bill lambert's shooting on one side
kareem sky hooking on the other like
first time ever seen the nba player and
he said i'll give you 20
if you go get kareem's autograph
and so i didn't say yes i didn't say no
but what i did and this was me as a kid
just understanding and being observant i
walk down there and i see other people
just kind of watching them shoot before
the game and kareem just focus just
shooting and it was astounding to me
because they didn't miss
but they were there early
and
i watched other kids scream his name and
he didn't even flinch didn't even look
in their direction so i kept my mouth
shut because i was like i'm learning my
lesson like i'm not about to ask
for autograph and then my coach knew he
was like kareem never signs autographs
but you know he was going to give me
that 20 if i got it but
just imagining if i got his autograph
then even to me and i don't think this
way but just you think about value from
1988
would i still have it would i've kept it
like
you just never know but that was my
early introduction to the nba and for me
for and i seen kareem walk in the room
and i've never told kareem the story
and when he walked in the room i seen
him uh during the final four a couple
years ago and then i seen him this week
the
all-star weekend and i thought
man he this was a guy that started off
with me yeah
it's great stuff uh congrats i don't
know if congrats is the right word but i
i i'm i'm glad that you had a good month
here because
you didn't do anything wrong but you did
you know we don't realize the
competitiveness the pettiness
you know that this means everything in
the world to these guys and it's hard to
you know you guys haven't played in how
long and kg's still holding on to that
because it meant so much to him and how
dare you leave them and you know you're
just trying to better your career but it
was a great moment great moment i'm glad
you walked on the floor and uh i
appreciate you uh you talking about it
ray
yeah yeah and it's fitting you know
thank you for saying that but it's
fitting and i'm sitting here talking to
you on st patrick's day so you know
thank you for uh i don't got no green on
but i got some green around me well
you've been cleaning your teeth there
great you've been flushing your teeth
there yeah well try to stay away from
the dentist two great shooters and uh
you know it my guys bring it up to me
occasionally that i did try to correct
you with uh the ball placement in your
uh in your hand that day when you came
into the man cave
yeah yeah i'm sorry you might be kg and
i might be you you might hold that
grudge against me for a long time
no they see the thing about a grudge uh
dan is you hold a grudge that means i'm
living your head rent free or you're
living in my head and i got to move past
that all right and i still feel bad
about that yeah
has anybody ever corrected you on your
shooting form
uh yeah people have tried okay uh i
remember i had a coach coming to
milwaukee he was like it was like my
fourth or fifth year and i had already
made the all-star team and he was like
you know
you you take the ball low first and you
gotta you can't do that you know he was
adamant about it and i was i was looking
at him i was like i don't i don't know
what you
what you want
want me to do but this is kind of
i go it's been working it's been worth
it
it's working out for me and and i think
even more so for all the kids that are
listening
you you know reggie was a great uh
example for me because
we're
when we're kids we're striving for
perfection people are trying to teach us
perfection
and then there's a point where you get
older where
our bodies are just what they are we
can't do certain things that other
people can do like you can't you know
when you think about golf swing
later on in life you just can't get that
turn the way you know certain people
certain kids can so
you got to teach a person based on what
they have you know what's available
physically
and so you know reggie he he crosses his
hands when he shoots
but he's a perfectionist at working at
it and figuring it out and so once i saw
how he shot
i was like however i shoot i just got to
be really good at and understand where
my deficiencies are like i know which
side of the floor i'm quicker on
than other so i got to work a little bit
harder and understanding eye dominance
so you you rotate a little bit faster uh
once you understand those things then
you can kind of
keep it the same on every side of the
floor always great to talk to you final
ten seconds he got game two what's the
update
it is stagnant you know listen we need
denzel washington on board if denzel's
on board he's got a spike is ready to do
this thing so paulie paulie would you uh
see if we can get a hold of denzel see
if i can move this along
and please
people are calling for it they want it
thank you ray great to talk to you again
buddy see you too that's uh ray allen
hall of famer take a break back after
this